this month millions of americans
traveled to florida in search of warm
weather beautiful beaches
and most importantly freedoms like
william wallace style down here
florida is open for business meanwhile
liberal governors and other states
are increasing lockdown measures and
destroying small businesses
in an idiotic attempt to battle the
pandemic they call it
following the science watch this
if we could go back now with everything
we know we would probably
all make some different decisions but
following the science i think has served
the state of michigan well and i'm
grateful for the incredible experts we
have
that was michigan governor gretchen
whitmer despite strict lockdown measures
her state is home
to one of the highest covet death rates
in the country
to the east the state of new york has
the second highest death rate
as one new york post columnist tweeted
out quote
anyone tweeting that florida is not
doing well is just hoping
it's not even debatable anything can
happen but right this minute both new
york and california
would trade with florida and everyone
knows it and florida's wide open
while california and new york are
crippled with closures
i live here it's true despite this
california is now planning to extend its
stay
at stay-at-home orders well after the
holiday season